dans le cadre de la 19ème édition du
challenge des créateurs une conférence
de presse s'est déroulée ce lundi 17
octobre dans l'établissement les
pâtissières gagnants du concours il ya
80 l'occasion pour le département de
rappeler son soutien aux créateurs
d'entreprises changent de créateurs est
une belle manifestation
parce que et je m'adresse à chaque
réunionnais ça permet à ceux d'entre
vous qui sont dans la difficulté mais
qui ont vu le créer leur affaire et
chacun d'entre vous vous avez un talent
et on le département va vous donner la
possibilité 1 à travers des aides qui
existent jusqu'à 8000 euros de prévoir
de subventions non remboursables et à
travers ce challenge des créateurs de
faire connaître votre activité
c'est à dire que le tchad des créateurs
permet de mettre en avant les
initiatives le mérite le travail d'un
projet original de nombreux partenaires
étaient présents tels que la cgss le
pôle emploi ou encore le conseil de
l'ordre des experts comptables de la
réunion tous soutiennent la création
d'entreprise et attribueront divers lots
aussi lauréat le pôle emploi participent
déjà depuis quelques années à cette
opération avec le conseil départemental
sous deux axes d'abord un axe financier
parce que nous contribuons à hauteur de
3000 euros sur
la mise en place de l'opération chaque
année il nous contribuons aussi sous
forme de mise à disposition de notre
personnel pour participer au jury de
sélection alors nous offrons une journée
de formation gratuite avec deux
expérimenta bénévoles qui vont aborder
un petit peu tous les sujets lors de
cette journée puisque on va parler du
juridique de fiscale du social de
l'accompagnement général stratégique etc
et donc c'est une journée des changes
surtout entre tous les créateurs qui ont
réussi le concours qui a été finaliste
en tout cas et nous beaucoup de
conversations des changes de formation
de réseaux se passe
mamie et christine ont reporté la 15e
édition du challenge des créateurs grâce
à leur salon de thé les pâtissières un
véritable tremplin pour leur activité ça
a été un tremplin aux usa permet aussi
moi je trouve les concours ça permet de
structurer jeu le discours sur sa propre
entreprise ça me permet de voir
clairement quels sont le voir qu'elle
joue
ce qui va vendre ce qui va permettre de
gagner qui va permettre de trois crans
mais quelque part c'est aussi une
reconnaissance de ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
fait l'amortissement les inscriptions en
ligne ont débuté le 3 octobre et
prendront fin le 7 novembre à minuit
rendez-vous sur www point cg974 point fr